- [Voiceover] What I
hope to do in this video
is a reasonably quick
justification of the idea
that the absolute value of a minus b
is equal to the absolute
value of b minus a
for any two numbers a or b.
And before I even break into this,
I wanna start with a simpler proposition.
The idea that if I have some number x,
and I'm just using x because
I already used up a and b,
that the absolute value of x
is going to be the same thing
as the absolute value of negative x.
And to feel good about this
we could draw a number line.
So we could draw
a number line,
and this is zero.
So there's one circumstance
in which x is positive.
Obviously if x was zero
these are both gonna be
equal to zero, and it would be true.
But one world where x is positive,
then negative x would be the same distance
to the left of zero,
so negative x would be here.
And the absolute value of
x would be this distance.
And the absolute value
of negative x would be
that same distance but just to the left.
So these two things would be equivalent.
Now if x were negative,
so let me draw that.
So if x were negative,
so if this was x,
then what would negative x be?
Well negative x would
be the opposite of it,
so it would be the same
distance to the right of zero.
So I know that this looks weird,
me putting the negative x out here,
but remember, x could be negative two.
And if x is negative two,
then negative negative two
is going to be positive.
But either way you see
that the absolute value
of these two things are the same.
The absolute value is just
the distance from zero.
This distance is still
going to be the same as this distance.
This distance is the absolute value of x.
This distance, in this case,
is the absolute value of negative x.
So hopefully you feel
good that these two things
are equivalent.
Now, if you agree to that,
now let's work on this a little bit.
So we can start
with the absolute value of
a minus b.
And there's a bunch of
ways that we could tackle this.
But one way we could approach it,
and actually let me write a little lower,
so I don't bump into this
stuff right over here.
So let me start with the
absolute value of a minus b.
Now a, we could rewrite, this is just a,
I don't wanna say it's
positive or negative,
a could be a negative number.
This is just a right over here,
but we can rewrite this
as being the same thing
as negative negative a.
Or I guess negative negative a plus,
minus b.
So let's just think
about this a little bit,
and make sure we feel comfortable
with what I just did.
So this a
is the same thing as all of this business.
The negative negative a.
The negative of a negative
is going to be a positive,
this is positive a.
So I haven't changed
this in any dramatic way.
But what's this going
to be the same thing as?
Well we can factor out a negative sign.
So let's do that, and actually let me,
we could factor out, using
a color I haven't used yet,
we could factor out the negative signs.
So this is going to be
equal to the absolute value
of, I can factor out the negatives,
the negative of,
and then I have open parentheses,
open parentheses negative a.
And if you factor out a negative here,
this is going to be positive b.
So or plus b.
Let me just close the
parentheses in the same color,
just to make them match.
Now why is this interesting?
Well we just said the
absolute value of a negative
is the same thing as, the
absolute value of negative x
is the same thing as
the absolute value of x.
So the absolute value of the negative
of negative a plus b is
going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal to
the absolute value, let
me do that yellow color
is going to be equal to the
absolute value of this thing
without the negative right here.
You see that right over here.
The absolute value of negative x
is the same thing as
the absolute value of x.
So the absolute value of
negative negative a plus b,
is the same thing as the absolute value of
negative a plus b.
And negative a plus b,
well that's the same thing
as b minus a.
I'm just swapping the
order right over here.
B minus a.
And we're done.
We've just shown that the absolute value
of a minus b is the same thing
as the absolute value of b minus a.
And obviously you hopefully
felt pretty good about it
by just trying out a bunch of numbers,
and thinking about the number line,
and thinking about what the
difference of two numbers mean,
if one is larger than the other.
But this is we're literally just really
factoring out a negative sign here,
and recognizing this property up here,
to make the same conclusion.